- [Princess Margaret] We're being filmed
watching television.
That people might watch
us, watching television,
on their own television sets at home.
- This really is plumbing
new depths of banality.
- [Presenter] --first
home computer terminal.
They're simple to operate,
and experts predict
that in 20 years' time, all
new houses will be built
with special computer points,
and that terminals will be cheaper to rent
than today's telephones.
- What do we do now?
- Do you expect us to say something?
- Yes.
- Well, what?
Did someone prepare something?
- I think the general
idea is it be unscripted,
to reflect a normal evening.
- This is nothing like a normal evening.
If it was a normal evening,
we'd all be on our own,
in sad isolation, in individual palaces.
We wouldn't be crowded like this,
this is like some sort
of nightmare Christmas.
(chuckles)
- [Presenter] Rex Malek
sees a future world
where children could be
virtually educated by computer,
where every home will
have its own terminal,
plugged into a central--
- Ah, perhaps Your Majesties,
Your Royal Highnesses,
perhaps you might comment
on what's on the television?
- That'd be easier if there were something
remotely amusing to watch.
- I agree, this is deathly.
- Things might improve with a drink.
- Everything improves with a drink.
- Not everything.
- Don't be such a prig.
Colin!
- [Director] And cut.